In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinoxadion from a fourth, on which we commemorate the memory of our
venerable father, Nikkephorus, the Hessikast.
Born in Italy, St. Nikkephorus was converted to the Orthodox faith, and abandoning his country
and his family through love of the truth made his way to Byzantium.
After the Compromising Union signed with the Latin Church by Emperor Michael VIII-Pelialogus
at the Council of Lyon's in 1274, he was condemned to exile.
It was possibly at this time that he composed a treatise on the procession of the Holy Spirit.
Desiring to confess the true faith not only through his words and writings, but also with
his whole life he embraced the monastic life of the Holy Mountain of Athos, the home
of virtue and the gateway from earth to heaven.
He showed a humble obedience to his elders for many years and was thus initiated into the
principles of holy Hessikia, the science of sciences.
He then founded a small community on the most isolated slopes of Athos where the monks
the whole inner way of life was directed to the guarding of the thoughts and to prayer.
To prepare his disciples for the battle against the powers of darkness, St. Nikkephorus composed
an anthology drawn from the lives and works of the Holy Fathers on sobriety, the guarding
of the heart and prayer.
However, many beginners were not succeeding in mastering the instability of their intellect
or news in order to pray without distraction.
He gave them a simple and elementary method which allowed them to find the place of the heart
and to invoke with attention the blessed name of Jesus.
If you ardently long to attain the wondrous divine illumination of our Savior Jesus Christ
to experience in your heart the super celestial fire spiritually to know and experience the
kingdom of heaven within you, then I will impart to you the science which will lead you painlessly
and without toil to the harbor of dispassion, apathia.
For we cannot be reconciled to God and assimilated to Him unless we first return or rather enter
into ourselves, tearing ourselves away from the distraction and vain concerns of the world
and in this way relentlessly seizing hold of the kingdom of God within us.
Before revealing his method, St. Nikkephorus recommends that his disciples lead a peaceful
life, free from every care and at peace with everyone.
When he tells them that entering their cell, they should sit down in a corner and recollect
their intellect, introducing it with their breath into the place of the heart.
If this exercise seems difficult and constraining at first because of the instability of the
intellect which rebels against this constraint, it will, with practice, find little by little
an indescribable joy in returning incessantly with the rhythm of the breath to this seat
of the soul, like a man who returns home after an absence and who cannot restrain his joy
at being with his wife and children once more.
Whether it succeeds in arriving at the place of the heart or contends itself with simply
linking its attention to the breathing, the intellect must never remain lazy and inactive,
but must reject every thought in order to cry interiorly and without respite, Lord Jesus Christ
have mercy on me, a sinner.
Testifying from his own experience, Nikkephorus assures them that this practice will unfailingly
open the place of the heart and that, with a joyful and most desirable attention, you will
see the whole choir of the virtues come to you, love, joy, peace, and the rest.
Thanks to them, all your requests will be answered by our Lord Jesus Christ.
Such is the famous method of prayer of the Hessikasts, who knew such great success with the
lovers of prayer and who also provoked such violent opposition from rationalist spirits,
those adherents of a holy exterior Christian life.
Saint Thelleptus of Philadelphia was one of Saint Nikkephorus' disciples and withdrew to Athos
because of his confession of orthodoxy.
He was initiated by the saint into this method of prayer and passed it on to Saint Gregory
Palamas, who showed forth its theological foundations and its central importance in orthodox
spirituality.
In old age, Saint Nikkephorus wrote a testament for his disciples in which he encouraged them
to guard an unsullied faith in the Holy Trinity.
He then fell asleep in peace.
Through the prayers of our Holy Father's, O Lord Jesus Christ our God, have mercy on us
and save us.